hey you're keith knight i'm an ally i
still post black squares to instagram
every week actually you can stop doing
that keith is not just an artist he is
an activist the correct term is artifice
okay
i have 15 000 followers damn keeping
cake
you wanted to be a big name activist
right congratulations you did that
my bro is headlining a protest no man
i'm trying to hit the club introduce the
ladies to these new abs abraham lincoln
kareem abdul jabbar let it rise up
sunshine i do hate police brutality but
i have to talk about other issues
so you can't solve one thing but you're
going to solve everything
thicker platform comes with a bigger
microscope and activists are vicious
i told you i got this share your
thoughts on hunger daylight savings time
save the tree frogs brother
look who's cracking under pressure look
i just got to figure out how to bring
people together
activism doesn't have to be heart
who wants croissants
that's the whitest [ __ ] i've heard all
day
what is this thank god almighty wi-fi is
free at last corporations are trash
who are you y'all got to get some black
and brown folks in here to tell you that
black wi-fi matters or whatever stupid
slogan you come up with next ain't cool
it's actually our first idea
the fist put the fist down
don't get so caught up in the cause
that you forget what is going on right
in front of
how are we supposed to understand each
other when we're all so different show
us how you wash up doing the pits nice
private
turn the water off and seize the day
what about your legs the water takes the
soap and it trickles down my body oh
so you think i should go on stage
say a bunch of vague yet uplifting [ __ ]
in a weird cadence like i'm at a poetry
slam exactly
one world
one dir oneness y'all i can't believe
you went full common girl everybody look
huh i love common
[Music]
you